so we've got a little bit more that
starts to shed some light this is not a
resignation on a matter of principle
this is a resignation on an honest
mistake here's what I understand
happened there was an incident I don't
know what the incident was but the
incident involved Zoella Braverman
sharing secure information that she
shouldn't do on a private phone and I
understand that is one of two reasons
that she has gone and I don't have you
the second one but the but the one of
two reasons that Zoella Braverman has
departed government is she effectively
broke the security rules of government
so it's not a it's not a national
security issue this it is however there
are lots of different classifications of
government material
um that are short of National Security
and she shared some secure information
on a private phone uh in a way that she
hasn't have done as she shouldn't have
done and she is out now
I think lots of people's heads are
spinning at this point I mean there's
been a lot of information that's often
shared on private mobile phones that is
security related not not least when it's
leaked to journalists so I think there's
going to be quite a lot of questions
asked about exactly how this all came
about and why this was a trigger and as
I say that is I am told is one of two
reasons that she is going and I do not
have for you the second reason uh but uh
it is clear that she is out of
government because there was an a
specific incident rather than a
resignation on a point of principle that
there is secure information that was
shared on a private phone and I am being
told that this was an honest mistake and
Zoella breatherman is now out of
government but there will be just so
many questions arising even from that
limited amount of information that I've
just been given the limited amount of
information I've been able to share from
you why was this considered so sensitive
is there precedent for it if it was on
the honest mistake why did she have to
go is it because she's home secretary so
you cannot Brook any kind of error in
that field but then
there's an absolutely inescapable that
we're in the middle of a massive massive
political crisis and Liz truss has just
lost the second uh member of her cabinet
a High um uh one of the uh in the top
offices of State in the space of what is
it five days